epa chief scott pruett says he is under
political attack because of his
effectiveness in pushing president
Trump's conservative agenda bruit has
been taking heavy criticism over issues
involving expenses and judgment he
talked exclusively today with Fox News
chief national correspondent ed Henry
the latest trouble for EPA chief Scott
Pruitt is a report charging he and his
team demanded big pay raises for two
longtime political advisors and after
age two President Trump said it was a
waste of taxpayer money Pruitt allegedly
ignored them and approved the pay hikes
including one for $56,000 though in an
exclusive interview with Fox and he
claims he was in the dark if you're
committed to the trumpet agenda why did
you go around the president in the White
House to give pay raises to two staffers
I did not my staff did and I found out
about that yesterday and I changed it to
be fired from that it should not have
been done in a minute maybe there would
be some kind of a little career person
or political person I don't know I don't
know you don't know who does found out
about this yesterday and I corrected the
action so we are in the process and
finding out how it took place but the
Atlantic charged the administrator and
his team filed a formal application for
the raises and when told no crew had
found a provision in the Safe Drinking
Water Act that let him do it a matter
now under White House investigation
the president has praised Pruitt for
cutting government regulations that
boosted the economy and saved taxpayer
dollars but chief of staff John Kelly is
also asking questions about reports of
Pruitt taking an expensive official trip
to Morocco and France and considering
but ultimately declining whether it was
a good idea to spend a hundred thousand
dollars a month to lease a private jet
plus questions about why Pruitt rented
part of this Washington condo from a
lobbyist at the below market rate of $50
a night led to Florida Republicans to
call on him to resign or be fired with
congressman Carlos Cabello saying
Pruitt's corruption is embarrassing in
Ileana Ross Lightman saying she's tired
of scandals while he got a lukewarm
assessment today at the White House
we're reviewing this situation we have
the chance to have a deeper dive on it
will let you know the outcomes of that
yet Pruitt blamed the left for targeting
him because he says he's a conservative
successful at shaking up Washington
President Trump said he would drain the
swamp I don't it's draining the swamp
renting an apartment from the wife of a
Washington lobbyist I don't think that
that's even remotely fair to ask that
question Pruitt repeatedly ducked
questions about whether he's made
mistakes himself he passed up multiple
chances to take responsibility for any
of these troubles we'll have a lot more
than interview next hour on the story
with Martha Chris I'm gonna get some
popcorn and watch hope so AB thank you